one of the reasons California at least
in my opinion brings in so many illegal
immigrants is that it inflates their
census numbers which then grants them
more Congressional receipts and more
electoral votes right so I always tell
people that you know they'll say illegal
immigrants don't vote they don't vote
and I'm like well at the at the federal
level they don't need to
if the census tracks X many people and
they get a I think uh in the 2010s they
had one extra congressional seat and
Electoral College vote one out of 538
votes you're absolutely right that's
that's that's that's a lot of power to
gain from doing what they're doing I
think they're called ghost districts
Maxine Waters gets elected with like
seven votes because her district is all
illegal aliens but by now in California
everything they've been coming for a
long time they are voting in California
we're just bringing in more and more and
more and why don't the Republicans do
anything about it
um and that's the donors want the cheap
labor yeah I had some of my best friends
in California were illegal aliens from
Mexico or or whatever and they would
work for cash and then they would send
it to Mexico I don't even know if it was
getting taxed no it's not if it's cash
that's just going across the border
there's no way to test it was like my
compassionate love was there but the
structural system wasn't working no it's
very bad for our country that's that's
money that's being sucked out of our
economy and by the way going directly
into the pocket of Carlos Slim who's
that
um the billionaire monopolist of Mexico
he's often competing with Elon as the
richest man in the world and how does he
make it by overcharging these poor
Mexicans so all that money going back is
to pay for his industry it's a very
corrupt country max doesn't doesn't he
own some big Media company or something
but he saved the New York Times that's
right the New York Times is he does he
still a principal owner no but he
stepped in at a crucial moment to save
them they were teetering on on
bankruptcy man I'm talking about like
Bloomberg buying it or somebody else
buying a Carlos Slim sucked in that for
us was a fortune Forbes Magazine had him
is the richest man in the world from
2010 to 2013.
Carlos so what is he like and he's
selling the a gorgeous Mansion in New
York City for 80 million it was just in
the daily mail yesterday whoa what part
of the city is that in Upper East Side
wow 80 million what the across from the
Met it's the red one right yes it's so
pretty it's magnificent what do we do
about the drug cartels that are running
people like drugs across the border the
wall the wall solves so every problem in
America gets easier with a wall every
single problem
um race relations poor people bringing
manufacturing back everything gets
easier when you solve immigration
because you don't have this we don't
need an extra problem to deal with and
extra poor people we have to pay for but
the drug problem that's 100
a function of not having a wall oh one
of the interviews I just did on substack
and I highly recommend you all watch it
so this guy Sam Quinones liberal
journalist but I've been a fan of his
for a long time he was a really good
investigative report you may have read
them in the LA times because his beat
was crime and immigration and he's the
only block quote I have in adios America
where it's like two paragraphs just from
his one of his articles really really
good and then he wrote what your
audience may be more familiar with he
wrote the book Dreamland about the
opioid crisis in America and now most
recently
um the least of us about Fentanyl and he
does the reporting he knows the drug he
knew where that all all the um the uh
the meth was coming from it was coming
from like one town in Mexico now it's
changed it's gone out to the cartels but
he knows everything about the drug
problem it is not coming from China it
is meth is being made in Mexico the the
opio it is all coming from Mexico is it
funded by the CCP
Chinese used to send the precursor
chemicals or they would send the heroin
directly or they would send the math
directly but the problem is that's all
in individual like FedEx packages
and they do it but for one thing weirdly
enough the Chinese government actually
did kind of step on them but it was just
inefficient you can you need to be on
the border you need to get it straight
across and you know they'll say oh but
it's not all Mexicans some of them are
American citizens yeah they're anchor
babies it is an all-mexican operation
interesting I thought I've been thinking
of it as a like just a continuation of
the drug war the Opium Wars the how the
British set up shop for Taiwan and then
just start shuffling yeah opiates into
China and the Chinese never you know
play the long game but you're saying
it's more of just a financial Mexican
issue right now do you feel like since
it's a fight and I think I'm sorry just
to finish that it is Opium Wars but it
is Americans against Americans the same
people who don't want a wall
um there is there is a crazy left I'm
not talking about all Democrats many
liberals are my best friends not talking
about all liberals at all but there is
an element of the left that just hates
this country and they're fine with
Americans dying of opioids they are fine
with a hundred thousand Americans dying
from drugs every year these people also
uh I guess paradoxically don't even know
what life outside of the United States
is they think the United States is evil
and they have no idea they've never been
to these other countries because if you
go to these other countries and you're
like wow America is pretty nice yeah for
all the bad things I remember when I
started traveling for vice after a
couple of these countries I come back to
the U.S and I I got like randomly
searched by the border patrol they made
me pull their pull my passport went
through my bag and I'm just laughing and
then they like they they see the Arabic
in my passport like what's this and then
I was like I don't even remember a
country that was Egypt I think or
something where did I go I can't
remember and I don't know it was uh
Morocco and they were like oh and then
they were like what's funny and I'm like
I love this country man I'm like it's
just like everything's nice here you
know I come back from I was in Brazil or
something and you know you see how you
see how good we have it it's
decentralized law enforcement is what
I'm I'm sold on the United States local
cops is the key to Prosperity having a
federal system where they're like they
decide one day that this is illegal now
and everyone in the country the key to
everything is the local yeah I totally
agree and I didn't know that until I
went to Cuba to um Chile and and Peru
and like saw the federal cops on the
corners I'm like we have no idea what
it's like in other countries especially
because we are so used to complaining
about America right everyone's saying
America's so racist and America has all
these cop problems and like travel at
all go anywhere and you'll be happy to
be here do you think that Mexico poses
enough of a threat to American lives to
be worth invading at any point
um I it wouldn't be necessary if we
built the wall yeah
um but yes to take out the cartels I
mean it's certainly more of a threat to
us than the Ukraine right and we sent a
ton of money shipping goods and
resources to Ukraine why wouldn't we
just spend that money on the wall on
well not only the wall but as for you
know going into their country
um I mean I don't know this is kind of
racy but yeah take out the cartels if
they can't do it by themselves well you
went we got remember that guy pineapple
face the first George Bush sent
um U.S troops he was he was I think I
was like four years old okay the
pineapple pineapple so the solid
nickname I'll look it up just
just
late 80s it was a big thing but it was
the first it was the first George Bush
sent in our our military to to to see
yeah yeah Manuel Noriega pineapple face
and he showed up on Google search really
Panamanian butts Panama
does it say Bush that isn't I maybe I
wouldn't have guessed
I've guessed funny uh why are you
thinking about him though because we
sent the military to get him
Noriega that was your question we've
done it before and wait if I could get
back to your point on local police it's
not just the police look at the covid
rules thank thank God I'm not taking the
lord's name in vain thank God we could
go to places like Florida
what if I mean Trump did shut down the
country you know because he's he's so
for Freedom
um
but New York California versus versus
Texas actually Texas wasn't that good
Georgia was good Florida was good I
don't know whatever places you were
looking at moving to in 2020 you will
remember everything should be local give
us a choice let us vote with our feet
yeah military centralization and
Military Authority law making and dude
the the medical tyranny is I am on alert
for medical tyranny I know the Nazis did
lots of medical science experiments on
living people and I'm not down with that
in real time we're doing it on
adolescent girls right now yeah we are
and they're miserable I mean with
medical tyranny during covid the local
governments were the most likely to
resist right bigger cities and everyone
else were more likely to give in if you
went to any small town in America they
operated differently they operated
independently because they know their
community and they know what they can
handle or the third largest state in the
Union Florida oh hey so what why this um
gun running that Obama did The Fast and
Furious program was he sending arm to
the cartels is that what happened
um what happened was
that's wow that's a blast from the past
um no
yes yes he was and the reason they
weren't intentionally hey we have a
program let's send although that was the
suspicion of a lot of Republicans they
wanted crimes being committed with
American Guns
um what they claimed to be doing was
putting tracers on the guns they were
sending and then they could follow where
the guns were going and they could see
where the cartels Hideout is and we
could follow the cartels except the way
it was being done was
so sloppy a lot of the guns didn't have
tracers on them way more than were
necessary they didn't follow where the
guns were going which made some people
think you just want an argument to say
all this cartel violence is being done
with American Guns we need more
restrictions on buying guns in America
I'm concerned about like um actively
giving our weapons to other people so
that we can test our own weapons against
our own weapons like in the Ukraine we
surround not in Ukraine geez we
surrendered in Ukraine and guys that's
what I'm about to say uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah Biden surrenders the military in
Afghanistan to the Taliban the greatest
military on Earth he surrendered it to
this local militant group the Taliban
for some reason
um and what is that reason well at first
I just thought it was incompetence now
I'm wondering if Lockheed wants their
arms in the hands of enemies so that
they can test their weapons because they
have no test grounds not just test but
so that there's a reason to sell more
weapons yes oh no the Taliban now has
you know Blackhawks and scud missiles or
whatever so you're gonna have to buy
more from us thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time